dieses stück zeigt uns doch dass es
schon immer gleich waren die frau die
frau ich verstehe nicht warum sie immer
von der frau sprechen
ich für meinen teil spüre nicht dass
meine seele ein geschlecht hat dem leben
was sie mir beweisen wollen ich bin
überhaupt keine absolute neigung für
nichts in dieser episode der
spielplanänderungen sprechen wir mit der
jungen regisseurin laura lad die das
termin ist ische film kollektiv rocks in
berlin mit gegründet hat und uns darüber
berichten wird die sie das stück gabriel
auf die bühne der theaterhäuser bringen
würde
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wer bin ich und wer billig sein
die frage nach geschlecht und identität
prägt unser jahrhundert queen's die
auflösung von geschlechter zuschreibung
der drang nach freiheit und dem man
zitationen jobs und erzählt in gabriel
die geschichte einer frau die als junge
aufgezogen wird und im teenager-alter
erfährt dass er eigentlich weiblich ist
also gabriel eigentlich eine gabriel ist
also klar es gibt diese wahnsinns
hauptfigur und das ist natürlich schon
mal ein emanzipatorisches moment dass da
eine frau ist die die männer attribute
erfüllt in der hauptrolle und ich meine
das war vor 200 jahren das darf man auch
nicht vergessen wenn man über das stück
nachdenkt und darüber hinaus wird ja
aber auch gezeigt dass diese
rollenzuschreibungen völlig völlig
konstruiert sind und dass das
gesellschaftlich gemachte zuschreibungen
sind und das macht das stück ja auch nur
sehr eindringliche art letzten endes ist
es gar nicht so sehr
ihr thema ist jetzt eine frau oder ist
ein mann was sie möchte ist
selbstbestimmt und in freiheit leben und
noch dazu kommt dass das ganze jahr
inszeniert wird also dieses verwirrspiel
mit gabriels geschlecht eigentlich aus
besitz gedanken heraus also sie soll
eine erbschaft antreten können das kann
sie nur als man also das heißt das finde
ich auch genial an dem stück das die
verbindung im prinzip von
geschlechterrollen und
besitzverhältnissen von geschlecht und
kapital mitgedacht werden und ja auch
auf den kopf gestellt werden
[Musik]
journalistin einer beherrscht hat das
stück gabriel bei einem spaziergang
zufällig entdeckt sofort hat sie sich in
die tragikkomische geschichte
ich finde es interessanter ist natürlich
von der frau geschrieben wurde also dass
man irgendwie auch feststellen kann das
schon im neunzehnten jahrhundert eine
frau irgendwie all diese themen anreist
die heute irgendwie manchmal so
präsentiert werden das hätte man sich
mit er ist der funken und eben also
diese frage nach nach geschlecht also
inwieweit ist das biologische geschlecht
mit eigenschaften wird verknüpft stellt
sie da hat es ja irgendwie eine frage
die wir uns heute vielleicht nicht nur
wirklich stellen auf jeden fall die
trotzdem immer wieder
ein brennpunkt ist als ich noch ein kind
war habe ich mich der gefahr
rückhaltloser ausgesetzt als heute das
lag daran dass ich mir der gefahren
nicht bewusst da ich ein zehnjähriges
kind das sich der gefahr nicht bewusst
war mutiger war als sie eine weise und
voraussehen da man ist daraus zu
schließen dass der absolute mut kein
absolutes attribut des landes sondern
vielmehr eines des kindes ist und wer
weiß vielleicht auch dass der gebaut
das theaterstück gabriel kann nicht nur
aus per minister lesart besprochen
werden sondern auch unter seinen
früheren aspekten und darüber sprechen
wir heute mit nina queer der drag queen
sie uns über die parallelen zwischen dem
stück und ihrem eigenen leben berichten
wird es geht ja wirklich und travestie
ja und das tolle in diesem stück ist
also für mich ist es obwohl es nie nicht
in einem wort erwähnt wird für mich ist
es hoch pornographisch ich habe mich
darin auch selber erkannt und zwar im
folgenden teil ich kann euch sagen
als gabriel das erste mal 'nen frauen
kleid anziehen und ihr bester freund
total scharf auf sie wird und sie sagt
warum siehst du mich so an
irgendwie hör auf damit und er sagt ich
kann nicht anders und so weil es gibt
keine frau die schöner ist als du und so
und da dachte ich mir um mein gott
kriegt jetzt kennt guckt euch das an
weil das war bei mir auch so ich war
immer so ein ganz anderes bürschlein in
der schule
und kaum zurück ich einmal
frauenkleidern da war es um mich
geschehen habe ich sofort mit fünf
schulkollegen und auch meinem besten
freund geschlafen das passt genau wie in
diesem stück und deshalb hat mich das
total berührt also und man muss sagen
dieser ganze inhalt obwohl nicht einmal
porno vorkommt oder irgendwann für mich
ist sehr hoch pornographisch hoch
sexuell ich finde
gleich am anfang in dieser alten schrift
da wird ja gar nicht von der wird ja
über den prinz geredet er ja der
erziehungsberechtigte ist aber alleine
wie dieser prinz und sein angestellter
der gabriel erzählt dieser lehrern wie
die über den reden da ist für mich schon
alles voll mit sexualität und
pornografie ich wusste schon ganz am
anfang ich brauchte eigentlich gar nicht
zu ende lesen ich wusste genau worauf es
hinausläuft weil diese geschichte auch
so ähnlich meiner ist und man sieht dass
spielt den ganz anderen jahrhunderten
ist es immer noch der kleine zeitung
die deutschen bühnen haben in den
letzten jahren einiges erlebt doch ein
stück wie gabriel war im repertoire
bisher nicht dabei
also da macht man dann eher noch die
tausendste inszenierung von kabale und
liebe
man hat das gestrige ist es was wir
sehen und du heute bist dann ist es
nicht
luise müller dann irgendwie lieber in
den freitod geht als ihre liebe zu
ferdinand zu beschmutzen also das sind
ja dann eher so die die frauenrollen und
frauenthemen die aufkommen letzten endes
finde ich den stoff ziemlich einzigartig
und gerade deswegen umso wichtiger
immer auf die bühne zu bringen oder
vielleicht überhaupt mal ins deutsche zu
übersetzen also ist ein echo auf ganz
viele fragen unserer zeit und ist darin
im video ist der klaren sehr richtig und
trifft viele punkte irgendwie noch immer
so sehr wenn gabriel irgendwann mal zur
aufführung kommt man kann ich ja wohl
nur hoffen entweder man fragt mich um
die hauptrolle ich hungere mich da auch
rein
oder aber man lebt mich wenigstens zur
premiere ein weil ich finde dass
stückchenweise
[Musik]
[Applaus]